this youtuber is getting sued because he
called a crypto bro a dirtbag and said
you shouldn't listen to his advice and
apparently it was so hurtful so damaging
that he's now being sued for 75 000
for defamation and emotional distress
now i'm obviously covering this lawsuit
because i get lawsuit threats a lot and
i always want to know is it actual
defamation or are you just trying to
silence criticism that's what we're
finding out today the lawsuit we're
talking about is between atozi which is
a commentary channel and bitboy a crypto
channel now you might have heard a bit
boy before because we've talked about
him in a past video called how much does
it cost to promote a crypto scam in it
we talked about the problem of paid
crypto reviews and showed how scammy
projects can pay influencers to promote
them sometimes secretly sometimes it's
disclosed now it turns out a month
before i made that video a commentary
youtuber atozy made his own video this
time called this youtuber scams his fans
bitboy crypto which is incidentally the
video which he's now being sued for now
in this video admittingly a tosi was a
little bit more colorful than i was and
he calls bitboy a dirtbag influencer
dirtbag influencer it has also been
known for being a shady dirtbag bitboy
and other dirtbag influencers dozie also
says bitboy can't be trusted with
financial advice he simply cannot be
trusted with financial advice because
you don't know if he's trying to enrich
you or himself and to support this point
he uses an example of bitboy promoting a
crypto coin called pamp in a paid
sponsorship i definitely don't want to
miss this one i do fair reviews with my
team and i won't promote something that
we don't dig deep into and that's
exactly what we did
the way pamp is designed is great for
staking if you missed out on tezos or
chain link you don't want to miss pump
by mean pamp i'm pumped up to talk about
this one yikes he pitched it as if it
was the next best thing but one look at
the current price of pam and it's not
hard to see why people are upset okay it
basically went to zero and bit boy
himself has deleted that video from his
own channel along with many others in
this cnbc article bit boy himself says
he could make up to a hundred thousand
dollars per month in promotions alone
and if they fail he might delete the
promotional video from his page so what
exactly is so wrong with what a tosi
said that would cause bit boy to enter
quote bouts of depression and suffer
from severe anxiety well this is where
things get a little weird one of the
core arguments of this lawsuit is that
bitboy is this incredible source for
crypto knowledge and advice this is why
it's so bad that a toasie has damaged
this reputation the lawsuit describes
bitboy as an industry-leading source of
reliable commentary which you know is a
bit of an exaggeration and they say that
quote can there be a more damaging
assertion for someone like bitboy crypto
who engages in the business of providing
advice and commentary on cryptocurrency
investments and this is where it gets
confusing because bitboy himself says he
doesn't give financial advice after all
i'm not a financial advisor i can't give
you financial advice courses financial
advice not financial advice so then what
advice are these lawyers talking about
that bitboy's in the business of is it
beard trimmings room decor it's not
exactly clear but what is clear is that
this lawsuit basically says atosi
defamed bitboy by saying the public
should not look to bitboy for any advice
but we have bipboi himself saying the
same thing so which is it seems like the
lawyers are a bit confused but that kind
of makes sense because occasionally
bitboy himself seems to get confused
because in that video i just showed you
about pam token he actually seems to
straddle the line between giving advice
but also making sure that he can't be
held responsible for giving advice boy
you always say do your own research and
don't trust anybody in crypto fair
enough voices in my head fair enough but
let this be an exception but of course
do your own research on pimp
so wait a second
should we make an exception for you and
trust your research or should we do our
own research are you a crypto advisor or
are you not well guys this is where i
realized that cryptocurrency is so
revolutionary so new that we need a new
theory to describe it so i'm coining a
new quantum theory term that i like to
call schrodinger's advice here's how it
works if a crypto influencer describes
himself as unfit to give advice he's
being responsible if you call him unfit
to give advice you're being sued now in
all seriousness i do kind of understand
why bitboy probably feels upset he
probably feels like he's cleaned up his
act and that people are still
associating him with a few bad calls in
january of 2022 bitboy said he had a
crisis of conscience and stopped doing
paid promotions which you know that's
great and i obviously applaud that but
you need to understand you can't fix a
bad reputation by suing your way out of
it you just kind of have to do better
and hopefully people will eventually
notice but speaking of trying to sue
your way out of it this all reminds me
of another situation pip boy got himself
into this time he tried to sue celsius
after everyone lost money and he was
gonna sue on behalf of everyone that is
until he realized he couldn't because he
had actually promoted celsius and
profited from that promotion so he
actually was a conflict of interest and
couldn't sue so oops i mean was that
financial advice should we have done our
research on that
it's not so clear so anyways that's it
for now i just wanted to say that i
don't agree with this lawsuit i think
it's frivolous to try to get a tosi to
shut up but either way don't forget the
most important thing
pamp the stock